hey guys it's Eric back for another
video and I was debating whether to make
you have another video on the Budapest
gambits or switch gears and cover a
different opening and I ultimately
decided that yes we do need at least one
more Budapest gambit video there have
been a lot of comments questions from
from viewers and I want to spend some
time answering a few more things and
showing just some more interesting lines
and I want to start with a correction to
something I mentioned in the first
Budapest video I uploaded in the line
where white declines and gambits and
there are a few people that reached out
in the the YouTube comments and also
just private messages saying that the
line I suggested was actually bad for
black and I will say that I did not
suggest the best line so in the previous
video I showed this line after Bishop c5
explaining black already has a good
position and then after Bishop to g5
this is a blunder due to Bishop takes f2
and so far this is all correct but after
King takes f2 turns out the move to play
is Knight g4 and not Nighy for think in
the video I said 94 and black wings of
Bishop and everything is good what I
didn't realize is White has a really
interesting resource after 94 and it may
require some help from the engine to
figure out what's going on in this
position and how white emerges okay but
I would encourage viewers if you don't
necessarily see the way that white is
surviving here pause the video and find
the best continuation for whites and to
my shock the move to play for white is
King III and if we turn on the engine I
don't think it finds any advantage for
black amazingly enough like that okay
the Kings on e3 and the bishops attack
twice
if we start looking at the variations it
becomes not so clear so the flock takes
on g5 with the Knights White has this
move H for trapping the Knights and
white is actually coming out better
despite the king being on e3 there's no
law or there's not enough compensation
for black losing piece and meanwhile if
black goes for Queen takes g5 then Y can
play King takes e4 and this is one of
the most ridiculous positions that I've
seen in a while but I was doing some
digging here and it seems like White's
okay even though the king is smack in
the center
Kahneman had the engine running a little
bit ago
you can turn it on now and we'll switch
views here at first it says Black has
some compensation but if you give it
enough time to think it struggles to
find some advantage I think eventually
it just decides that black has to go for
some repetition some very strange
repetition Queen g6 King III Queen b6
and of course on a practical level this
is probably still playable and it's
probably still room for white to go
wrong for example King f3 apparently
being the best move I think it would be
very easy to play King d3 a line like
this okay black has some compensation
it still looks fun to play for black
King f3 the computer sees no better than
then Queen f6 and going back and forth
so I'm sure it's possible to do a lot
more analysis from this position but if
you're playing this line is black I
think all you need to know is that you
should not play 94 but rather play
Knight g4 avoid any line where the King
comes to win the Knights and and this is
just crushing for black
I think there is another comment that
mentioned if let me switch views here
that in this position after Bishop to g5
another possibility is 94 and this is
also nice for black kind of a fancy idea
that if white takes a queen then it's
made in one
I don't think 94 is as strong as Bishop
takes f2 immediately for the reason that
white can play Bishop e3 here and it's
still better for black like black can
take play Queen Queen h4 gets a little
bit weird like g3 Knight takes g3 Knight
f3
turn on the engine here and see what it
thinks saying Queen h5 rook g1 yeah also
better for black but my personal
preference would be to go for the bishop
takes f2 line so hopefully that clears
things up and yeah if people have
further questions or further Corrections
please let me know in the comments but I
do want to move on and show some some
new variations new insights I'm gonna
switch chapters here and I do want to
note if I switch views again that all of
the analysis I that I'm doing can be
accessed in this Li chess study
everything's organized into chapters and
I'll leave a link in the video
description so people are free to check
this out and do your own analysis so for
now I'm gonna move on into chapter 4 and
I want to start from this position and I
want to show a line that I think a lot
of players who play the Budapest maybe
wouldn't be familiar with because it's
it's one of those variations you might
overlook when studying an opening but
it's not that easy to figure out what to
do against so the line I'm referring to
is in the main line after Knight to g4
White has seemingly very a very powerful
move at least it looks powerful at first
Queen d4 attacking the Knights defending
the pawn and really putting question to
black what to do here and this is
actually a good moment I would encourage
viewers to pause the video and try and
find the way to punish Queen d4 I will
say that there's a very very nice
response from lack which leads to very
pleasant position so black to move find
the best move and the move is pawn to d6
and it's a multi-purpose move first of
all it's defending the Knights secondly
it's attacking the e5 pawn and it's
attempting to open up the position in
blacks favor if the position opens up
then the Queen will potentially be more
vulnerable on d4 so after d6 we can look
at a few lines let's imagine white takes
looks most natural and then it may seem
possible that black could take with the
bishop but I wouldn't recommend leaving
the g2 pawn hanging the move I recommend
here is knight c6 nice move attacking
the Queen again note that the knight is
defended on g4 so black is just keeping
some initiative
now if white really wants to be greedy
and hold on to all the material possible
like can go for Queen before check
preventing black from recapturing
immediately and forcing black to block
the check and now there's a really cool
line coming up okay black can start with
Bishop e6 developing blocking the check
and let's imagine White's
takes on c7 if we count material White
has not lost a single pawn yet and black
at least temporarily is down three ponts
and I will say it looks very natural for
black to just recapture and try and get
some compensation but I will say that
there is a better move than Queen takes
e7 here and it's a move I discovered
earlier with the engine very hard move
to finds but I'll give viewers a chance
to pause the video try and find the best
move for black which is not Queen take
c7 and the move just kind of comes out
of nowhere
Queen d1 check now the move that you see
every day especially when there's
nothing on d1 the point of this move is
of course that we drive the King to d1
and we set up the fork on f2 and very
quickly lack will win back material and
just have very nice play
okay the King has to move of course we
recapture the Queen and the c7 pawn is a
goner once black win ce7 which could be
any time reasonably soon then black will
just be down one pawn but there's
massive compensation here I mean white
has nothing developed there's ideas of
Knights to d4 Knight B for targeting c2
and we should note that the King is tied
down to defending f2 not to mention that
black has Bishop c5 coming to further
fight for the FQ square also the c4
plant is hanging to so this just looks
like a terrible position for whites and
I think the computer agrees computer is
giving some evaluation when I first turn
it on saying minus 0.3 so maybe not too
terrible but it's usually a pretty good
valuation if you're down upon but the
computer still favors your sign so okay
hopefully this helps some people if you
ever encounter queen g4 just know to
play d6 and if you remember this Queen
d1 idea yeah could be helpful in that
line so one more variation I would like
to cover there is a comment which I did
not take a screenshot of but someone was
asking about middle game plans emerging
from one of the main lines
so I wanted to take a moment to show
just a really nice instructive game
which very nicely demonstrates one of
the main middle game plans from the
Budapest so let's switch to chapter 5
here and we'll go through with the main
typical variation see for five takes
Knight g4 and now there's a moment
coming up which I didn't mention in any
of the previous videos but it's
important to point out that if white
plays Knight f3 before playing Bishop to
f4 then it opens up another possibility
for black now of course black could
still continue with knight c6 and after
Bishop f4 things would transpose but if
you get to this position I would
recommend starting with Bishop to c5
this is a nice nuance essentially
forcing white to play pawn III there's
no other good way to defend f2 pawn and
after pawn III of this Bishop on c1 it's
a bit more sad I can't develop actively
and now black can continue with knight
c6 and very easily when back to pawn we
can imagine if light plays Queen d5 then
black can play simply Queen e7 and the
pawn on e5 is just a goner so going
forward from here I do want to show how
the game can unravel and how black
should not only complete development but
know what to do in the middle game so
let's imagine play continues Knight c3
take c5 let's say the Knights get traded
I will say that there's another
transposition which can arise if you
take on e5 and white plays Bishop to e2
black could take and after white takes
back black could go 495 and in many
cases white is inclined to play Bishop
e2 to hold on to the bishop pair and it
would be essentially the same position
in this game
white took immediately black takes back
and then Bishop e2 castling castling
now black plays rookie AIDS very
flexible move in some cases if this
night comes to e4 or a4 then it's common
for the bishop to drop back to f8
keeping the Kings side safe getting out
of the way of everything else in this
game white played pawn a3 and this is a
very typical plan for white is to try
and expand on the Queen side with pawn
before and of course fianchetto the dark
square Bishop to b2 so in this position
there's a very the mattock and natural
preventive move for black simply Pawnee
5 preventing before trying to fight for
some space on the Queen side and there's
another idea of a5 which is a little bit
hidden and normally white will play b3
here again trying to continue with the
fiend kettle and in this position I
would HIGHLY encourage viewers to pause
the video and try and find some plan for
black like how would you continue over
the next next few moves if you had a few
moves in a row what would you do to me
not only complete development but fight
for some advantage and I think a lot of
players would consider something like d6
and then just developing the bishop
normally maybe to f5 and then then just
play chess which is a completely fine
way of playing the thing about this
position is that there is another very
unusual idea but it works in this
position for the reason that there's
nothing on the six rank for black and
black can immediately go for the rook
lift with rook a6 and it looks very
bizarre but this is actually a difficult
plan for a white two to meet because
very quickly black wants to play rook h6
Queen h4 and just create a mating attack
and the combination of okay eventually
playing d6 and having the LightSquared
Bishop to help out the knight
centralized on e5 there's some very nice
harmony
for blacks pieces so I want to show a
game between two players that took place
in 1993 I don't want to hurt myself
pronouncing the names of these players
but I'll switch the view here just so
people can see some person was playing
lights and then some person was playing
black so the game continued Bishop to b2
rook h6 and now Knight to d5 so White's
trying to get some play at least in the
center unleashing the bishop
centralizing the Knights maybe having
some ideas of 9.4 black simply responds
with d6 and now like it was for b4 so
finally achieving the expanding move on
the Queen side and the beautiful thing
coming up is a black just completely
ignores a pawn on d4 and focuses solely
on the Kings side and the next several
moves if I'm not mistaken just for the
rest of the game black just continues
making threats until white is completely
lost so the obvious move to play here at
the move I basically already mentioned
Queen h4 going for the mates on h2 only
one way for white to defend pawn h3 and
now there is a very juicy looking
sacrifice it's actually hard to call it
a sacrifice because if white takes it
white will just be dead but the move as
Bishop takes h3
yeah just destroying the Kings side if
white takes back then the Queen can take
and I don't think there's any stopping
some kind of meats on h2 or h1 so in the
game white was suffering white could not
take the the bishop that rather play
pawn g3 black continues making threats
queenie for saving the queen threatening
mates on angie to really only one way
for light to stop mates is to play pawn
f3 which is a very unfortunate move for
white to play is now
it weakens the defense of the e3 pawn
box simply takes it after Knight takes
c3 Queen takes e3 rook F to the position
essentially played itself Queen g5
targeting g3 and white white played one
more move Bishop e5 rookie five and then
played one more move after this Bishop
f1 and just ran into Queen takes g3 and
then it's just just forced me from here
but already at this point white is
pretty much hopeless like even if white
plays a move like g4 trying to stop
Queen takes g3 then there would be Queen
h4 and the Queen is just infiltrating
almost impossible to stop Queen g3 and
then there's gonna be all these mating
patterns with the rook on the h-file so
this was a really nice game I believe
the white player in this game was rated
over 2,200 it's a game I just found in
the masters database on me chess so not
a bad way to to crush a master with the
Budapest gambits okay hopefully these
these lines give some more insights into
how to play the Budapest aggressively
and and effectively and I would
encourage people to explore on your own
feel free to investigate further on the
leech a study everything is here people
are more than welcome to use a opening
Explorer to find games and research the
most popular moves I think it's best if
you have a Lee chess account to to
analyze and I'll show one more trick
here that if people want to kind of
analyze on your own and save all of your
analysis you can very easily go to clone
the study scroll down here and just
click the clone button and then cloning
the study will just create a study that
you own and then then you can you can
even add your own
actors or change the the privacy
settings so really have to think leech a
story for allowing some some really nice
functionality so I think I'll end it
there hope you guys enjoyed that as
always let me know if you have questions
or feedback in the comments and I'll see
you guys in the next video